Speaker 1: There was another rally this past
weekend.
It wasn't just the crazy, anti-vax rally.
There was also the completely unhinged, more
religiously oriented anti-choice rally.
They call it the March for Life.
It's really the march against choice, against
bodily autonomy, against allowing people,
mostly women, along with their partners who
could be male or female, to make decisions
about what's best for their health and their
pregnancies.
This is the very long, long time in existence
now March for Life, and many of you are already
familiar with the endless hypocrisies with
these March for Life people.
But the Good Liars did some really good work.
They went out to the March for Life and they
interviewed some of the anti-abortion people,
and they seemed completely unable to understand
the irony and hypocrisy of the things they
believe.
Here is a really great example of an anti-choice
guy being interviewed about my body, my choice,
which he says doesn't make any sense when
it comes to abortion.
But when presented with that, when it comes
to vaccines, all of a sudden he says, Yeah,
my body, my choice completely impervious to
hypocrisy.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: What message would you have for
women who are considering having an abortion
Speaker 4: when when a woman becomes pregnant,
there's two bodies there?
It's not one, and it's not my body, my choice.
Oh, it's care for care for the child.
There's adoption, there's there's other routes
to go.
Speaker 3: And what do you what do you say
to people out there that that say that they
don't want to get the COVID vaccine?
Speaker 4: If my body, my choice works for
abortion, why doesn't the same work for the
vaccine,
Speaker 1: which of course, you could say
the same thing, right?
If.
Wait, hold on a second.
If my body, my choice works for the vaccine,
why couldn't it work for abortion?
Like without a hint of irony?
Speaker 4: If it's my body, it should be my
choice of whether or not I want to vaccinate.
Speaker 1: These people and the theme here,
by the way, is a lot of just telling other
people what to do.
Another really common one is never, ever,
ever abortion because there's adoption and
a lot of these people that advocate for that,
they go, well now.
I mean, I'm not adopting anyone but other
people should.
All right.
So here's another interesting interview from
the good thieves.
The good liar.
Speaker 3: Sorry, I saw the sign.
Choose adoption.
And how many?
How many children have you adopted?
Speaker 5: Not able to adopt.
I'd love to adopt.
We weren't able to adopt.
Speaker 3: And how many children have you
adopted?
Speaker 5: I have two of my own.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
And how many children?
How many children have you adopted?
None.
And how many and how many children have you
done?
I have two of my own.
So you've adopted.
OK.
The message?
Speaker 1: OK.
So understand that this is all about telling
other people don't have an abortion ever,
because instead you should pursue adoption.
And also telling other people, go and adopt.
I mean, we're not doing it.
No, we're not going to participate in any
of that.
But other people should not have abortions
and then other people should adopt their baby.
It's all about what other people are supposed
to do.
Here's a bonus this is Jeanne Mancini, who
runs the March for Life, saying that they
have been praying and fasting to earn to end
abortion.
I didn't know that they were fasting.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: I have never seen the enthusiasm
of the pro-life movement like I've seen this
year.
It's like we have prayed and fasted for years
for this moment, and we're so hopeful and
positive that Roe will be overturned.
Speaker 1: I had no idea that they were fasting
to end abortion.
Now I don't know a lot about fasting.
The closest I would ever get would be as a
kid.
The first two hours of the Passover Seder
felt like I was fasting, even though I had
not actually fasted.
And until the matzo ball soup came out and
we could have the food.
That's so I don't.
I have to admit I don't know a lot about religious
fasting, but I did not realize that they thought
fasting would end abortion.
I had no idea.
Every little detail about this is outrageous
and just just rally after rally and the fact
that people go to this stuff really showing
us the dire state of the discourse in the
United States.
Speaking of dire state of discourse, I have
an invitation to some of you this weekend,
Saturday, January 29th.
Donald Trump is doing another 2022 rally.
This one is in Conroe, Texas.
We would like to hire someone from our audience
to go to the rally and interview.
People live will be on a stream and some day
they'll do some interviews.
And also I will feed them some questions that
I have for the Trump rally goers.
If you so, here's the deal we will pay you.
We only need like one team, probably one camera
person.
Or, you know, maybe, maybe one.
You might even be able to film yourself.
But if you can get yourself to Conroe, if
you live in the area and you can figure out
how to get in right, like either you get a
ticket or you get a media registration, we
can't help with those details, but we will
pay.
We will pay you to go and do this and you
have the equipment, which is like a phone
at this point.
Basically, we want someone to go and do some
interviews at the rally for us.
So get in touch info at David Pakman dot com.
Don't ask us how to get in.
You have to look and see what the ticket situation
is like.
We were just it's too soon to handle all of
the logistics, but we will pay.
We'll come up with something.
Fair info at David Pakman dot com.
Ideally, you would live nearby.
It would be easy for you to get there.
Get in touch if you would be interested in
doing that info at David Pakman dot com